mitochondria is the powerhouse of the
phone coming Astro hello and welcome
back to the lab where we take your
questions and turn them into experiments
my name is Mitch and I'm Greg and today
we're going to be getting hung over for
science no seriously there are a lot of
claims for different scientific hangover
cures but we thought we'd take some of
the more simple ones that are backed by
science and test them on our cells the
reason we've got hangover in the first
place has to do with a few thing as you
drink the alcohol actually promotes the
excretion of many components like
sulphate Adam and glucose which are
required for normal muscle coordination
and brain functioning but perhaps more
important is what happens in the liver
your liver takes an alcohol or ethanol
breaks it down into acetaldehyde and
eventually into acetate which is easily
extruded by the body but the problem is
that there aren't a lot of enzymes to
convert it to acetate meaning the more
you drink the more that it accumulates
and acid aldehyde itself is 10 to 30
times more toxic than alcohol leading to
headaches and feeling nauseous we are
here in LA with mamrie Hart
tell us about yourself ok well hi I like
long walks with the EPA my name is
maimry and I have a channel called you
deserve a drink where i make original
cocktail and I've had more hangovers
than nation survive so we're going to
make a drink for us tonight but first we
got a key so we're starting out with
fatty foods because it slows the
absorption of alcohol into your blood
and lessen the stomach irritation
well carbs on the other hand prevent low
blood sugar and easier nausea which is a
good thing because I haven't barf from
drinking in a long time and I don't plan
to vomit yeah that's why you're so good
we fight so much we swim 10 mins ago
I'll do it again below Tama like I think
I get more hungover when I pop around
yeah I danced with everybody that was
cute from drinking and I'm good I think
I had a pretty bad one a couple weeks
ago so you didn't draw my life my phone
yeah not more than growing up eating
helps your body have more time to
eliminate the harmful byproducts of
drinking about getting food with your
buddies and some examples after the bar
is actually too late it's important that
you eat before you drink or even while
you're drinking because this can
actually decrease your piece blood
alcohol concentration by a doe 2/3 but I
always eat when I'm already drunk yeah
crime is an idea I'm a cheap drunk yeah
next up we get to start drinking but
we're going to stick with a lighter
color liquors because dark drinks like
bourbon or even red wine contains
something called congenita stalks the
chemicals your body is going to have to
get rid of that can cause inflammation
so now we want you to make a drink with
this clear vodka okay well I figured a
good like safe thing it's just like a
boxer so honored yeah here we go you're
really gonna look real on this awesome
most bars a lot of a free pitcher of
water and you need to keep your eye on
it and keep drinking it because a big
part of hangovers is dehydration because
alcohol makes you excrete more water
than you take in this affects your body
and literally makes your brain shrink so
you need to make sure you're chugging
water when you've at home and put a
glass of water beside your beds that you
can drink it as you wake up in the night
we're going to try and match how much
we're drinking and alcohol with equal
amounts of water see my body just
normally has an aversion for water smell
so I'm trying to treat it with the red
cup pouring Cheers
have you guys ever been sober over where
you take a difficult water you're like
water water is good yeah like you just
discovered it a lot of water so much I
wanna bring a lot of different pills in
the substances claim that they can help
your hangovers but most full short when
actually studied and in this video we
really want to focus on simple solutions
and cheap solution but a recent study
looked at something called a Kiwi
empanada which is an extract from a
shrub native to Japan and found that it
actually does help in minimizing
hangovers so we got our kannada extra
the moon and helpful bit more we love it
and if this works they will be making
their money oh yeah we should buy some
corn off it off Cheers
Oh time for the more water water heart
forever so we just wrapped up filming
with mamrie are we wasted or what that's
a very Christ wash yeah so we just watch
mamrie is hydrating and we're going to
go for some more drink more vodka great
feeling on a tipsy if you like I should
have a hangover tomorrow but so we got
like gank guess you come about a fresh
juice watermelon lime please this is how
you know I'm in LA
for bed we took some aspirin which has
been shown to decrease something called
prostaglandin which ultimately
contributes to hangover Jannah that is
constant - oh wow I don't even II do not
do this at home you're telling me - no
don't do 17 of the cells that actually
didn't taste bad but try to stay away
from its - the minute vent or Tylenol as
it can be harsh on your livers enzymes
and in conjunction with all the drinking
you just did to do some real liver
damage of course now we get to see if
any of these solutions actually work and
if we wake up feeling any less hungover
than we would have on a night of
equivalent drinking I don't know so work
I look dreadful
I kind of feel I don't know if I feel as
bad as I would having to drink that much
but I'm definitely hung over her I think
I'm feeling okay I definitely am a
little hungover but I got them all night
water and I'm having water now and then
I do think am i based on that cement
alcohol and I drank that another time I
would be more however but it certainly
wasn't a fix-all just enough not feeling
perfectly not like I work it's
technically not over yet we have some
morning routine stuff that can help that
we're going to test out so we'll give a
full review by midday of how we feel
foods like eggs bananas and fruit juice
help to replenish your electrolytes and
contain nutrients and compounds which
actually assist and break down the
remaining alcohol in content okay so we
made it to midday and feeling a line
absolutely better Allah God I do go much
better I feel like even though this
wasn't a perfect test I'm sort of
comparing to other childhood dreams of
the same immense I have been a worse off
all of it yeah but but definitely I felt
like I became less than over faster than
I normally would yeah we drink lots of
water and again everyone's body's
process alcohol quite differently this
was in no way a perfect test but
obviously being conscious of trying to
not be hungover the next day will help
you in some way so thank you for
watching you know follow these steps
because they did help and then let us
know in the comments if there's anything
else you want us to test out absolutely
and make sure you go launch mamrie Hart
video that we did on her channel doing
some shit also balance and alcohol
experience it's really really cool so go
check it out on our Channel and we'll
use it